[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record we talk about whatever we
want tim is back oh [ __ ]
he's never left in case you haven't
noticed i've been here just chilling
lives
at this office chia misses them yeah
it's true whenever there's another guest
here i'm just under the table
rubbing their knees the knees
whenever they make a good joke i'm like
good one dude
yeah you're like yeah
[Laughter]
i like that who's rubbing your knees
randall park
no he was here earlier he is such a
chill dude
yeah very chill yeah i thought he was
just tired but i'm like no you're just
chilling he's really chill yeah man nice
guy
nice guy i think he's in the
at the same time i think he's in the no
i was going to say the first time i was
going to say and i told you guys the
story off camera but
the first time i ever met randall park
we were at some event randomly ran into
each other downtown la
and um and i was like and i was like hey
it's
the uh it's the original asian dude from
a while now and he's like yeah that's
the new asian dude in a while and now
and then we like
dabbed and it was funny so you didn't
introduce me to him
somebody introduced me to him a good
chunk of that video
with him trying to figure out who it was
that introduced him and he said it was
you
yeah but no cause he met he says that we
he actually remembered that i
that we had a text conversation but he
had a better memory than i did
because i thought he was going to big
hollywood me but what ended up happening
was
i dumb hollywood of him because i was
like oh dude
you know it's so cool that tim
introduced us and you guys were like on
wild and now and all this stuff and he's
all like
no i think we had our conversation
before i met tim
and i think it might have been one of
the wongfu guys and i'm all like damn
you are a true human being yeah i didn't
introduce you guys
i think maybe phil did shout out to phil
on your face i didn't introduce you guys
shout out to the film
that's my thinking face okay so it could
be ted here's a weird chance to want to
give feel credit
my apparently my um trying to figure
things out face
according to my wife and my good friend
rick is a very
condescending you're an idiot fake can i
see what that looks like so
okay i don't know what it is but i'll be
in discussions with them
and then when they say something that
when i'm like processing and i'm
thinking
they're like oh that face you look at me
like i'm stupid
does it does it make does it look do you
look like you're smelling cocka
i don't know what can i do it yeah
because i i've observed you for years
sure um you do this thing where if
somebody is
talking and you're trying to understand
them you're like
oh i have seen that face from time to
time okay that is a tim
rick is always telling me he's like that
[ __ ] face you make man
and then she is like she'll lit we'll be
talking about something and mid
she'll be like oh that face i hate it
damn
like she hates it they know you so well
that they can point out the face yeah
and so now they don't take it personally
well so now i get frustrated because i'm
like okay can we just can you just move
on because this is my face at this point
like y'all you're gonna think right now
yeah like are you trying not to do it
now or what i
so now when i know that i'm confused or
i'm trying to figure [ __ ] out i'll look
away
because i don't want to make them some
people have a concentration [ __ ] face
though hyper awareness
that's a concentration [ __ ] face it's
not it's not resting
because you're focused it's not written
focused [ __ ] face yeah dude
you also can't be next from mirror
because if you're like
but then they see the mirror and they're
like i still see you tim
so much that i have to worry about now
just what i'm trying to think
now you should just start looking like
this everywhere you go
and with that hair that's the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um and then when they start explaining
things to [ __ ]
call like this with your lips
that'll throw them off guard dude a
little mini bubbles popping
ah what i was going to try to say before
tim ruled the intro oh damn you
it's not even that important but it was
just what i like about randall is
he he just treats random he just treats
um
i think like the industry as work
you know he just seems like a guy like
oh yeah like you know i'm
an accountant or i'm an engineer or
whatever so he's just like he he doesn't
make it like my life is about hollywood
about making it and being in every
single tv show
that is my identity yeah it's really
about like i have my family i really
love my family i like doing stuff with
my family i'm a kid i take them to
school
and then when you go oh what do you do
for work i'm like in production
like he's not like i am a actor yeah
have you seen
i've been on multiple seasons on tv he's
not like well when i was with stephen
earlier
uh spielberg i think you're gonna say
green yeah there you go i think that's
why you feel so grounded just like a
regular person can have
conversations oh that's true cause i
would have been like
i was with my friend cool you know
coolio yeah we were just hanging out
and i'm like where is coolio the fact
that that was your go-to
that was your in your brain as your
go-to celebrity shout out because of the
hair i get it
oh yeah and the jersey did you wear lots
of jerseys like twinsies and [ __ ] you
know
like but i'm only bragging to when i
brag
i'm bragging to my high school self and
my junior high self and my friends in
elementary school
like people that i know today i don't
have a reason to
right because it's it's not fun they
have better things to brag about to you
than you do to them
that's why you don't do it no i i wanna
i want my
childhood friends to be like coolio
you know what i mean like you never do
this when you go on ebay you try to buy
that thing that you never got to get
like the pirate's lego set and you just
kind of you could buy right now but you
just like
if i wanted that too how much is that i
didn't say like i bought a grill
i wanted that how much is that dude it's
probably it's expensive now
it's a collector's item it's because
everyone all the all the kids who grew
up want it
right [ __ ] it's like it's like a
thousand bucks or something well they
don't make
new pirate legos no we're talking about
the one in the ninth
one the one with the red and black sails
yeah
the jolly roger baby is that the one
with the legos were like not the small
regular
bricks but like the bigger bricks it
looked like it looked like a real chef
back when they only had
the three colors yeah red yellow white
or black and
[Music]
it was a ginger captain with a peg leg
and a hook
you guys know what i'm talking about the
only place there was ever a ginger
captain anywhere and then he sees
you never you never think like i need to
accomplish this
because the the six year old in me
is like i needed this [ __ ] though i
needed
i need to [ __ ] go i need to call my
friends in fourth grade and be like yo
remember that time when we were like
talking about wouldn't it be cool
if we met the [ __ ] nate dog and the
bone thugs and harmony
i met them isn't that dope all right
cool
you feel fulfilled i wish i could go
back in time and laugh at all the chicks
who laughed at my [ __ ] pokemon cards
binder
because i had a first
edition venusaur card which is now worth
like a grand or some [ __ ] where's it now
well it's like compared to back then
[ __ ] bought it for like a buck that's
a lot for a card tip
you're gonna sell it i don't even know
where the [ __ ] it is she's the girl that
laughed
and she's still laughing at you how do
you feel that was
me i don't like it when women laugh at
me
but so what disturbs me about it is that
my mom is such a hoarder i can't find my
collection
but it's there though i have it though
technically you can trust that
isaac had a phase with pokemon cards and
i bought him a pokemon binder
so the front like the whole binder was a
pokeball
and it was pretty cool and now where is
it he got rid of it
you guys don't no wait i think we still
have it you don't time travel
i saw like when you like um like let's
say like you're on a jet ski or
something
and you time travel back to when you're
like 14 and you're like oh man
yeah that happens frequently especially
with smells for me too
like i'll time travel back to the moment
that it reminds me of that
smell like when you grew up in mexico
you're like this taco yeah like when i
was born and raised in mexico
man one of the best fish tacos i've ever
had was in
um ensenada and it was um from a little
cart
oh so far that's the city with the big
flag right have you ever had tacos
these are tacos that are like they're in
vapor
and then they're like really soft and
delicious vapor and vapor what do you
mean by invasive
vapor i'm saying these you're like theme
steam
tacos steamed tacos is what i'm trying
to say is there a shell
yeah yeah no the regular tacos yeah but
they
they're kind of like cooked oh they're
cooked in steam oh
and they exist in steam we're very uh
you're like
they're like here you go and you're like
oh my favorite taco
like chef chef do it again i can catch
it i missed it i don't catch it i'll
catch it
here's your vape tacos
they're so good oh man they're the best
in guadalajara
when we're on the way to the airport
because i'm like we [ __ ] have to have
these topics
some are in a taquito shape and some are
in a baby taco how come they just look
like regular ass tacos yeah why'd you
even google the images because they just
like
that is true i'm looking at the images
like these exactly like the tacos that
aren't steamed
right here steamed like this these are
seams yeah we could read it tim
we didn't we don't get a feel it looks
like a taco though
i'm sure it's delicious oh these oh
okay i'm really hungry
those look like the mini tacos from jack
in the box
i know they're bomb they're mommy i know
i know i know is it crunchy
um or is it like soft you're talking
about jack in a box you're talking about
the the vapor taco no it's like a mix of
like crunchy
soft mainly soft i need to go to
guadalajara just for that
they're so good guadalajara is pretty
cool waddle the jar
i've been to ensenada and i gotta say i
did not have good tacos i don't like
ensenada that was nothing that's
literally it's in the name
yeah i had tourists trapped tacos damn
that's a fire taco
i have water from mcdonald's there but
you know i went to uh
uh michoacan and there's this [ __ ] out
there that you can only get out there in
[ __ ] morelia which is where i was at
i've been there
okay so this is [ __ ] right it's like a
it's like a fruit it's like a fruit
thing but then there's cheese on it and
they're called uh
gazpachos yeah and it's like you can't
find them anywhere else
and i've been googling to see if anybody
out here in la has it
and my boy or one of the guys that works
for the crew that i shoot
skits and [ __ ] with he's like bro you
can only get those in morelia
yeah every like region and at least in
mexico they have like their
their thing when it comes to cuisine and
food like for example like with
guadalajara it's it's um
which is tortas but then they drown
us means drown so you're drowning them
in sauce so they're just these like
you know what bolios are you know that
bread that looks like a football
no bread that looks like a football oh
football bread
bread football bread but aside from like
food you know what makes me chill out
is cbd oils because today's sponsor is
brought to you by
feelsback oh yeah and um you know you
know i usually
rely on food to relax me like sometimes
i eat a big fat meal to go to sleep and
all that stuff
but um i found that feels they hooked me
up with a box
you drip a few these feels oils in your
mouth
nice little cbd takes a few minutes it
just kicks in
and you go to sleep because uh i
couldn't go to sleep on empty stomachs
before
but now when i'm trying to dye it i just
use the fields instead of
getting the uh super duper food coma you
know what i mean
so if you want fields and have a good
night's sleep it can help you too become
a member today by going to fields.com
off the record and you'll get 50 off
your first order with free shipping
that's feels f e a l
s dot com slash off the record to become
a member and get 50
off your first order with free shipping
that's off the record use that code
that's mother knight yeah if you show us
football bed right now it looks like a
loaf of bread i swear to [ __ ] god
i swear to god i swear to god
that's not even a football bread where
the hell where'd you go these are what i
was talking about
where'd you go with your thought
training is that assorted fruit we want
to see a kind of a ball that you a
bread that you can spiral through oh
i'll show you a [ __ ] bread like
you better wait what is that it's a
fruit cocktail these are the fruit cups
but it's cheese oh dude it's so good i
know it sounds crazy
it's cheese it's shredded cheese have to
do with steamed
tacos and football friends this is the
tortas with the the football brand
you've seen the [ __ ] football bread
it's this one that looks like a good
sandwich
all right yes it looks great it looks
wet that's what i like about it
means drowned drowning
yes drowning i like mexican food because
it's like kind of the same flavors but
so many different shapes
so many different shapes i didn't
realize until
dating casey that mexican cuisine has
almost
no vegetables in it the raw radish
it's cabbage radish
some cilantro yeah beans are veggies no
those are
those are no they're like
yeah legumes are corn
i mean there's tomatoes but they're just
kind of inside the sauce
fruits they just squished it okay what i
mean to say is we don't
we don't consume our vegetables the way
chinese culture does yeah you don't have
like
leafy greens where the entire dish is
just leafy green
the same people who go pluto's not a
planet yell at you about tomatoes being
a fruit
all right well they're both a fruit and
a vegetable
oh well that's flat now you're getting
greedy yeah that's what i've heard i
don't know
you gotta pick it once and that's what
they told me what's what's the drown
again
[Applause]
back to this so you're saying it's fruit
with cheese it's fruit with shredded
cheese so you know shredded cheese yeah
we go to the fruit carts out here right
cheese
and it's like a crazy [ __ ] i don't
know hocking cheese or some [ __ ] man i
don't know
it's just bob sweet cheese is good like
cheesecake
i've never had anything like it anywhere
else and i try to find it but have you
ever had bionicles
in yes are good what is that
so it's a sliced fruit like different
kind of fruit and then you put
condensed milk on top of it i had that
and then you put like shredded coconut
yes i had that and um and a football
bread
no of course not but you get it at the
fruit area
yeah at the fruit
yes man i think about this [ __ ] all the
time i love it but
there's nowhere to get it except for
[ __ ] random ass morelio
the gummies as a kid where it had a foil
back to it
and then it was molded to some kind of a
weird plastic shape in the front
i haven't been able to find it since
it's the same kind of [ __ ] it had
gummy bears no it wasn't gummy bears it
was a gummy that came in a plastic
container like a tray thing yeah with
the foil background
silvery foil background and it tasted
different than any gummies and then you
peel it yes
and it kind of reminds you of that
sticky hand that you can snap around
yeah it's like softer like more wet
gummy it's the same kind of [ __ ] i've
been able to find it since i don't know
where the [ __ ] it is
different shape yeah there's like worms
hands whatever
but it's like a it's like a it's like
sounds so something imagine a vacuum
sealed
like case like of a gummy bear what is
talking about it's pointless it's like a
few likes before mine they used to have
them at liquor stores
yeah something like that yeah but
they're like wet gummies
yeah exactly they were delicious i don't
know as a kid anyway you never know as
an adult
it's a gummy dela
so gummy of the drowned yes of course
this is exactly what i said what the
heck
i can't find it so i i just recently
special ordered some [ __ ] gummy bears
from canada because
chia says the gummy bears out here are
too firm and
she was like because i ordered some
harley balls rebels are the best
i i love them but she was like oh no
this is way too hard she's like babe you
got to try these
from canada that i love they're called
maynards maynards
and so i googled them and i ordered them
from canada for her i haven't tried them
yet but they're supposed to
be like way way way better than the
haribo no that's what she says
my whole thing about haribo is that the
texture but the texture is perfect on
haribo especially when you put it in the
fridge
it's perfection you make it cold yeah um
she likes just the
like the old school i don't know man i
think the australian ones are the best
you ever had those they call them
lollies no would you like a lolly it's
like
it's it's like gummies but they use
different sugar right
i think they use [ __ ] beet sugar or
something else
but it's like the texture and everything
it is next level dude dude your
australian accent is
on point by the way i'm on a [ __ ]
point it's like like a little
like would you like a lonely love yeah
no that's british
no it's australian you got to get more
drunk with the would you like a lawley
oh that's pretty sick it's like it's
like
that's really good something is mad
that's what is a little more aggressive
british accent
a little more drunken british drunk and
aggressive no
no no
no speaking of gummies have y'all ever
had the secret menu jamba juice
smoothies what the hell that one oh you
don't know
okay so jamba is a secret menu and one
of the most popular secret
menu items there is the white gummy
smoothie and it tastes just like a
[ __ ] white gummy bear
just maybe fatter bro everybody used to
order that [ __ ] and that's the thing
i've heard the the secret menu items
aren't on there because they're more
they're they're more sherbet heavy so
they're not as healthy
but white gummies bomb you get a red
gummy bear i do believe white gummy bear
and um it's bomb and one time when i was
a waiter at california pizza kitchen
i had a uh a table that they were like
higher ups
at jamba juice right and um
i was talking to them and i was like
yeah yeah blah blah blah
why gummy bears secret menu she was like
oh you don't even know there's like
screaming jesus the purple dragon she
was naming random [ __ ] i was like why
can you just go to jambo juice and just
say random names
oh it's funny you said that because one
time i told my boy i was [ __ ] with
the homie and i was like oh bro you
heard the white gummy bear well i just
had a green jolly rancher and he was
like oh really and he went
to go order one he's like i'm the green
jolly rancher and the lady's like
uh i don't think we make that one here
he's like oh okay
well uh they had it at the uh the
cerritos one it's just kind of
bullshitting so i guess that one's a
little more secret
so all of them know the secret menu yeah
if you go to any jamba juice and you say
let me get a white gummy bear they'll be
like oh okay and they'll make it
do you say any of this by the way at a
weed store and they'll just start giving
you
hey give me a pineapple sunrise and
they're like well you do have it that is
a strange yeah i don't know give me a
xylophone
uh cobra no that's not a stranger you
all got red motorcycles no sorry that's
ecstasy
yeah that's about you're in the wrong
store for that
you need girl scout cookies
[Music]
you